because the up teeth keep open girly
just said the next numbers died state
how's the fan how's the fan dude look
like King Kong Kiki yeah yeah if your
mentality is looking for a reason to get
out of it it's not gonna last long
yeah cuz it's easy to find an excuse
that's good yeah it's real easy yeah
they come to you you don't really need
to find them that's the thing right now
yeah especially with social media do you
think that's a part of why you guys lean
more to the right more of a no excuses
man I gotta lean to the right more
because they got common sense yeah but I
mean that is indicative of your
character like you said a lot of people
say I watched you when I was training
you guys are still training do you think
that lends itself to being more sort of
rugged individualists yeah I suppose
you're right you never thought of it
though oddly I started going right
because it's just an it's that common
sense thing to do if you know if you if
you little most people don't even
understand why they liberal where I just
do it because it makes them feel good
but maybe what I'm kind of asking is
maybe it's common sense to someone who
sticks with it I mean right for most
people it's not common sense it's not a
typical decision to go man I'm out of
shape at 34 I'm going to go to the gym
and stick with it and start you know a
fitness channel Empire on on YouTube
with millions of subscribers that's not
really common sense I wonder if maybe
you would drive more for like I always
wanted to have my own business growing
up I never really wanted to work for
somebody some people you know they got
more Pancho pearl entrepreneurial spirit
I would say that's reason why we lean
right well we stuck to the gym so long
the causes some you have to go get you
have to earn it
yeah somebody's not gonna give it to you
and where did you guys bring
entrepreneurs before you've got I know
you were in the military in the Marines
yeah first job before we went Marines I
was vacuum cleaner salesman
yeah where's independent contractor so
we're self-employed yeah I so Kirby
vacuum cleaners door-to-door yeah hey I
got some free coca-cola you just won a
free carpet gym I'm gonna try to say
this $2,000 [ __ ] you but I'm not gonna
tell you that yeah
yeah we still knock on doors you want to
free coats and a what's cozy yeah this
is gonna turn it about $3,000 as utility
inches and everything but yeah he's a
freak these are $1,500 apiece
did you sell a lot of vacuum cleaner oh
my god I was 18 I was making so much
money vacuum cleaner I sold I was
getting about what three to four hundred
dollars per vacuum mm-hmm and that was
selling like ten a week and he it was a
bad master he was a bad master so he had
he was driving a van right you have ten
people if and he would throw them in a
house and then he will go in a house and
try to sell one and you'd get money for
the ones they sold to yeah I wouldn't
get as much but I get like maybe a
hundred hundred each time they sold it
was making like like how much you guys
paying my mama's rent my rent I was
sending you money yeah she was still in
high school he was making like you made
like one week like 10,000 bucks
oh man this is back in nineteen their
early 90s early nineties why a week and
you were never a van master he got hot I
have to disappear fired he got me fired
oh he got you [ __ ] he want to bard a
company van to go see some ugly chick
[ __ ] a nice body though like just be
careful cup was his mom he said all's
good sweet balls on there because your
teeth keep open girl X numbers dad how's
the fan dude look like King Kong Kiki
that's what is that sure the elbows die
cuz uh the van didn't have a radio in it
so I broke a little boob ah look like
driver right the dam boom box falls
publish I need to listen to my Jodie's
you picked it up I feel like this almost
would open overpass hit the damn breathe
I broke all four axles Wow I got off the
fan pissed all over myself
Jason oh my god their boombox it was
killer
it was more so user error of their box
yeah I called my boss up Isaiah was the
name Jesse Justin man he's healed amen
brother ones died
almost died I let him take the company
van he wrecked it
how's the freaking face the freaking oh
well he told me look like King Kong
chicken farm wait cause it inward to
what he cut I have been cutting it where
somebody was a white guy here's a white
guy you a racist would imagine racist
you like the Dallas Cowboys this baby
boy was Emmitt Smith you know what I
think his wife like you know I know she
did go back on a fire Thomas you know
take care hey but you know what if we
didn't get far from those jobs we men
never went to the Marine Corps because
it was making way too much money man
yeah you did as a people and why do you
say he wasn't racist why do you think he
called you the n-word you think was just
mad trying I just I think people say a
lot of stuff when they're back I mean
they mean it at the time but do
incentive to yet mr. mom what did you
say when he said that honestly now it's
just like I kind of deserved it take it
like a man I was like yeah yeah I mean I
haven't been called the n-word but I did
get fired by a french-canadian
Nordstrom's yay Wow yeah yeah I got
fired for juggling sheep they had
stuffed sheep stuffed animal sheep and
they caught me on the security 101 was
in there a full but go they'd have sheep
and sit there now I try to juggle he's
just like little stuffed animal their
Christmas sheep and then they'd brought
me back in and they made me watch myself
on video yeah and the funny thing is now
it wasn't just that but I had I had
asked for I told him I wouldn't be able
to work unless that American
Thanksgiving off because I was in Canada
they said okay and then what they called
me on the American Thanksgiving oh you
have to come to work I said nope not
coming to work I just hung up didn't
explain myself and then I didn't go in
the next day just to piss them off so
they called me in to fire me and they
bring up the sheep and they show me the
Sheep and I I don't know how I did it
but I argued with them this guy Carl who
was my supervisor at the french-canadian
Nordstrom's he's talking the men's
underwear section and he was total
sexual harassment he would say things in
French like oh my boyfriend is a little
Lang he has a cute little butt like an
Anglophone like you means like an
English
person there and I brought that up when
he fired me and I was like you know they
just thank God I'm not gonna bread on
you know I'm not litigious and I argued
with him until he said okay well fine
you can stay but it has to be 180 and as
soon as I said no no I quit argued with
them until the fire was removed I was
rinsed and and immediately quit and that
was uh but he didn't call me n-word but
he did call me a lot of other names yeah
so we win in the marine Court when did
you get out what was that went in and 94
no that's what went in no it's been a
while we got 94 you got a little bit
earlier I was in 94 to 98 well how long
between the Marine Corps and then when
you start sort of the fitness thing what
were you doing between that oh man
awesome hey that's security guard I was
a deadbeat for years I was looking for
some I didn't know what I was doing I
was bathroom security job is to security
job uh we did get a stamp with doing
private investigator yeah oh really yeah
what was that like you were private
investigator so you just jump right
people yeah probably best get used to
tell people yeah most of time is just uh
like personally enter your file people
did be lying about the injuries oh no
how many people I get them on film going
to the doctor's office with a crutch
yeah well wolf or KNK walk you get in
the car and leave after duck spawn Nick
just run it up to third that's a great
doctor you would you go say I want to go
see that chiropractor hey could you just
you would help insurance companies yeah
what I would shoot beat over up report
city city sometimes we would do
infidelity investigations like follow
people's husbands and wives you know
what a lot of that came up even though
we was watching before like insurance
claims that stuff will come up it wasn't
part of the case was just like a free
show you know and did you bring it up
did you ever tell the spouse or if it
wasn't it wasn't your business yet
there's masturbation material I don't
think you were supposed to take video I
think you were just supposed to take
notes
that's old port investigation evidence
70 you still got that lost it computer
crashed
no it's Elvis he said he's telling you
that now he just wants to keep it all to
himself that's what's happening he still
has it all right so you guys have lived
a very full life I didn't know all this
yeah what else I used to do they ever
tasers trip up my dad just being in vans
used to these to return recycled paper
newspapers that's what they would do is
they would they way that they way your
car and they way it with the newspapers
in they take it out and then weigh it so
it would go by weight that's what you
were paid huh and the reason they got
kicked I don't know what it's called
like a loading I don't know what it was
called a weighing station I don't know
but they were banned they weren't
allowed to go back you know why they
were put in magazines between newspapers
to increase the weight and then they
were and they would take some newspapers
and hose them down so they were
collecting all this coin they found it
like we have a bunch of wet newspapers
and magazines in here you can crease the
way well I think I don't think it lasted
very long I think they were looking for
they don't think they were the first to
pull the old magazine and wet newspaper
we also went to a porn audition together
yeah got stage fright dog couldn't
perform you go first no I know you go
first
that was weird that sounds very weird I
don't even know if I want to ask about
the story oh man we was filling out the
paperwork and it was a since the first
questions are you down for gay porn I
was like Hills knows about some glory
hole action I like some girl it was uh
it was a Asian woman there and a white
woman my god the Asian was you know
white woman like a beat-up prostitute a
used tough one long bleep ed um I'm in
my shoes there was other guys coming in
at the audition and did it was just big
fat white dude Cavey
that's like this deal was to be a porn
store so they take him to this room and
he's got like I guess he'll perform in
some way for him and I can hear the guy
going oh man oh god oh god like oh I
think I think the guy just busted
okay he comes out of room right he's
sweating profusely and his face is
betray it's beet red man that was a pop
orgasm oh man sorry I assumed you didn't
go through with the other
yeah we're skinned up mumbles go see it
yeah boy we're cousins do hey Christine
you see what you boys up to who's your
cousin
Ilyn Omar there was a job when I was in
lost it wasn't quite that colorful but
in Los Angeles where they they asked me
to clean houses in my underwear so look
at me yeah but it was it was turned out
it was gay homeowners and there'll be no
touching real bean and i remmber talking
with my brother was like it's kind of
like it's something like 65 bucks an
hour just to you know go out there with
a feather duster and some tighty-whiteys
no no that's how they suck you in yeah
yeah they grooming you that's what you
think yeah one day some dudes will pop a
corner pretty much you doing a great job
my name is Larry
yeah the foresight to not do it you went
right into the belly of the beast there
at that audition I don't know what you
expect straight poor man with broke man
we needed money yeah the year was 1998
member - you broke that we needed losses
after the Marines yeah yes after marine
like right when we got out man we needed
money man you know what that right there
should be a PSA for a politician saying
we don't do enough for our vets yeah and
show them just the hodgetwins this man
couldn't get what he needed from the VA
[Laughter]
hives twins tor.com thank you guys for
being here I always appreciate and I
respect that story you guys are usually
gentlemen off air yeah they're good guys
I don't know somethin except I don't
know how you end this we'll see you
[Music]
okay if you liked this video you know
you watch videos on YouTube a fiber
Jimmy Kimmel if I were Stephen Colbert
or Trevor Noah I would tell you to
subscribe but I have no corporate
overlords who demand that I do this
demeaning promo I do the demeaning promo
because I choose to subscribe or hit the
notification Bell because I need you I
need you please do it